[Music]
[Music]
how's it going everybody it's warren and
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about all things
marvel and sometimes we talk about dc
as well and today we got our very first
tiny little teaser at the rocks black
adam the nemesis
of shazam now i played this this morning
on my dc and other movie channel
cosmic culture be sure to check it out
if you haven't head over and subscribe
if you love dc
star wars and other awesome movies as
well this morning dc
officially released all of the guests
that they're going to be having at dc
fandom there are a ton of celebrities
showing up including gal gadot
and of course the rock the rock joined
dc by taking on the character
black adam and this morning on twitter
he released
a tiny little teaser and our very first
look at black adam now it's very quick
if you blinked you might have
missed it but it is nonetheless our very
first look
now what we're looking at here seems to
be the rock as
theo adam uncovering the tomb of the
original black atom
the original black adam was known as
teth adam and he was born in 1279
bc where he tried to rule egypt at the
time he was granted the powers of shazam
but his powers were taken away from him
and his powers were taken away and
placed in a mystical scarab
necklace when the magic wore out black
adam would end up dying because his body
no longer had the magic to prevent him
from aging and his body
and the necklace were placed in the tomb
of ramesis
ii later on theo adam would go on to
discover this tomb and he would end up
being the reincarnated version of black
adam and that is what i believe that we
see
right here i believe this scene right
here is going to be the rock as
theo adam discovering the tomb of the
original black adam and becoming
the new black adam it's a quick little
teaser but the rock did release this on
twitter
with the words they needed a hero
instead they got me
excited for the first ever global
celebration of the dc
multiverse tag dc fandom this one's
just for you the fans around the world
stay healthy my friends and i'll see you
all on august 22nd
the man in black black adam dc fandom
has promised a lot of exclusives and a
lot of new
stuff and it seems like some of that new
stuff could be for black adam
possibly seeing the rock in the black
atom suit for the very
first time at dc fandom so if you're a
fan of dc be sure to check out dc
fandom on august 22nd and subscribe to
my other dc channel we'll be doing
constant updates over there but
let me know in the comments down below
how excited you are for
black adam and do you think the rock
does better as a super villain in the dc
universe or would he do better over in
the mcu leave your thoughts down below
don't forget to like the video and
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the big
dc news as always thank you all so much
for watching
woof